welcome the best life 30 your 30-day
journal of creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
convenience worksheets check the link in
the description below alright today is
day one of 30 and we're gonna learn how
to get inspired it's hard changing your
life it was hard when just over three
years ago in the Penobscot building in
Detroit Michigan where I was operating
my business and I fell on some hard
times and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope and he said would
you mind reading it here and I opened
the envelope and the envelope was from
management that says this is an office
tower it's not a hotel please do not
sleep in your office and I said excuse
me sir I said I just worked long hours
and creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor him and two
other dreamers up there look at him it
was hard ladies and gentlemen coming to
speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I can do it
there were times that I doubted myself
and say God why why is this happening to
me
I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a Rob from anybody how did this
have to happen to me it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you for
those of you that have experienced some
hardships don't give up on your dream no
one could have convinced me by holding
on by continuing to push forward by
continuing to run toward my dream that
one day I would have my own talk show
it's a long shot ladies and gentlemen
from Liberty City an abandoned building
auto flaw never annoying my mother or
father it's a long shot
being here with you today in this dome
in Atlanta it's a long shot no college
training labeled educable mentally
[ __ ] but I kept running toward my
dream
goes down
Goldstar
[Applause]
don't stop running to watch our dream
second in say if you want to be more
inspired nature one of my favorite
protocols is the daily nature walk I
love walking in the woods I often listen
to audio books in the woods
I call it walk reading while walking
reading while walking so I go to this
place it's sort of my creative forest
there's not a lot of people in there and
I walk for one hour I breathe in the air
I look at the lush scenery I listen to a
different audiobook I it's almost like
walking meditation as well sometimes I
don't listen to an audiobook and I just
walk and I touched the earth it's almost
like I'm thanking the earth connecting
with the soil yes I'm wearing shoes I
don't want to get too esoteric here but
there's a lot of really good research
saying if you want to boost your immune
system you want to boost your happiness
you want to release serotonin and
dopamine you want to release the fear
hormone called cortisol walk in nature
and so when I walk I connect with nature
and like I say I know I'm not being very
elegant in this mastery session I'm just
being real but I listen to the audio
books and then other times I do a
walking meditation where I feel my feet
on the soil you know what I do other
times if there's something I'm confused
about I sort of just talk it out it's
like I'm talking out loud trying to work
it out if I'm in pain I get the negative
negative energy out of my system by just
releasing it by talking about it I also
and I know this sounds a little
unorthodox but I I do like a a walking
blessing meditation so while I'm walking
I started to challenge myself to come up
with 50 things I'm grateful for and
again I verbalize those because it's
only me and the squirrels in the it's
hoping me and the squirrels in the woods
and so I say I'm grateful for my family
I'm grateful for my health
I'm grateful for work
feeds my soul I am grateful for the
sunset I watched last night I'm grateful
for my team I'm grateful for my business
I'm grateful for the travels that I get
to take I'm grateful for the people that
I've served and literally while I'm
walking I say out loud I am grateful for
I hope it doesn't sound strange for you
because it's an incredible protocol to
install your 47 what is the likelihood
that you personally will go tomorrow
70% you've recently made never
breakthroughs that I but that I'm just
really fired up about and when does that
happen in our lifetime yeah yeah I'm
talk about moving there so it's like if
you get the price figured maybe around a
couple hundred thousand dollars this
could be an escape hatch for rich people
no you're probably if Diane Maas is much
higher than Earth really the Africa to
Mars would be like Shackleton's Africa
Antarctic it's gonna be hard as a good
chance of death going in a little can
through deep space you might land
successfully once you land successfully
there will be a mat you'll be working
nonstop to both the base series you know
not much time for leisure and once you
get there even after doing all this is
very harsh environment so use a good
chance to die there we think you can
come back but we're not sure now is that
sound like an escape hatch for rich
people and yet you would unhesitatingly
cup you know there's lots feel like
climb mountains you know why they climb
mountains because people die on my
divorce a little time they're like doing
it for the challenge this disease will
not defeat us this disease will not
break us it make us better and everybody
knows my family knows that we took a
chronic illness
it's a chronic illness and we took our
marriage to another level
we took her chronic illness impedance
and we will continue to beat it until we
destroy it that's what we violated and
so she go over accent are you here I'm
saying stop you cannot play the doctor
gave her a long needle like that I said
how long does she have to do it
she said she has to do it every day I
said okay every day long she said every
day for the rest of her life I said I
don't know nothing said that there are
things in your life that you are
accepting because somebody told you got
accepted I don't care you a doctor that
I will not accept that we will not they
will not shoot Erwin we will not give
her a shot with that needle every single
day for the rest of our life three
months later I got the call that says
that now this little shorter and you
only have to do it three times a week as
opposed to every day that's what I'm
told
I sound grateful I still don't ask
children sometimes do you think that
because it's only good I will be excited
I will not accept it stop accepting
everything stop letting people tell you
what you can and cannot do
I will not accept it I don't care if
you're a doctor I will not accept this
don't do no homework they found out
about appeal and she can take I was like
that's what we need we need to peel the
peel shits the leeches on your brain
I went to the doctor she said I would
have told you about it going on I don't
think your insurance company
willing to pay for his $2,000 a month
hundred twenty thousand dollars a year
sure it's called me deny if I went back
the second time they denied so when I
stop banging on 121 give you $2,000 a
month or do I keep your hundred thousand
dollars now to get it for a year I will
not I will not let my life whatever it
takes I will not let her take the I will
get 120 I would spit more I will get
better I will get degrees I will get
training I'll do whatever it takes I
will put your health first and it will
not be defeated
it will not be destroyed you will not
lose a king will not be in a wheelchair
we will beat this some of you in this
room you are not able to activate your
greatness because every time of trial
and tribulation comes so you give up
everybody every time somebody calls me
tell you can't do it you take it
personal every time somebody tells you
you don't have what it takes you embrace
it and now you gotta stand up to it I
never did one time of my life I never
felt this urge I never felt that it was
impossible my wife told me just a couple
days ago she says today I feel I can't
help before I got in this she had a
weekend where she felt great and I told
her it's for we can to gain some
for the rest of your life we will not
break we will not retreat will not give
up we will activate our greatness and we
will know what is right to live the ones
one say I will watch come on you make up
your mind you will live to 120 I went
from being homeless eating out of trash
cans traveling first class hundred
thousand dollars an engagement back to
home every star NBA NFL whatever I
consult them when I got to Dallas I was
a bartender at night and I moved in one
of my buddies from Indiana said you got
to come to Dallas anomaly I'm there you
know my car would only get so far he had
a Fiat x19 with a hole in the floorboard
that guzzled oil every 60 miles and I
went down there and there's place called
the village it's the world's was the
world's largest apartment complex we had
six guys in a three-bedroom apartment I
didn't have my own room I didn't have my
own drawer I didn't have my closet I had
a pile and I had one ratty towel that I
stole from Motel six and that was it
and so I was looking for my career got a
job at a software store and I was you
know I was didn't have a tech background
so I was teaching myself all this
because the way I look at tech is
somebody invents it and everybody else
is tied for second place and the ability
to learn it and if I work harder and
faster to really dive in in if it means
reading the manual you know just diving
in then I can get a head start like you
know you almost 24 and so sleeping on
the floor working in a software company
you know learning learning learning
learning learning getting better what I
was doing and then one day because I was
dying to get out of that rat hole that I
lived in I had a chance to go out and
close the sale for that wood he got me a
$1,500 Commission and so I went to my
boss his name is Michael humic and I
said boss one of my responsibilities was
to sweep the floor wipe down the windows
and open the door to open the store I
got the sale you got to let me close the
sale
he goes no you got to be any to open the
store and I'm like Michael I mean no so
I made the executive decision to go I'll
pick up the check thinking if I hand
this guy a $15,000 check of course he's
gonna change his mind
fired me on the spot and so here I was
living in Asheville excuse my French you
know just this ratty place with a motel
6 towel sorry motel 6 and and really
didn't know how I was going to get out
but I went to I decided ok I'm a lousy
employee I went to one of the companies
that I've been talking to architectural
lighting and I said look I need $500 to
be able to buy the software you want and
I promise you that even if it doesn't
work I will wash your car you know I
will walk your dog I don't care what it
is I will do whatever it takes to make
it up to you and they gave me the $500
and that allowed me to create micro
solutions and you know six months later
I was out of the rat hole and my company
turned into a real company and that's
the one I sold for 6 million dollars
when I was 29 30 years old I was at the
gym yesterday and a woman drove by me in
a wheelchair at the gym I was working
out pretty hard and she wheeled by me
heavyset lady in a wheelchair I'd be
honest with you I watched her wheel past
me she inspired me do you know what
courage it takes to get in your
wheelchair and decide I'm gonna go to
the gym right I'm gonna go to the gym
she's heavyset awkward that inspired me
far more than the jacked up dude doing
60 pound curls I mean that's inspiring
but you see that a woman in a wheelchair
at a gym with her two pound dumbbells
because her legs don't work but she went
in there anyway and you know how
unsecure she was about going in there
she's the only person in a wheelchair
she doesn't know what she's gonna see
how people are gonna react to her she's
not in shape just never full makeup on
and her little you know halter top like
the other girls in there and she's right
in there she was right in there working
out right next to them right I couldn't
take my eyes off her I couldn't take my
eyes off her and I ended up telling her
this she was leaving I left what I was
doing I walked over ice I just want you
to know something
you're inspiring me this is wonderful
her face just lit up because you know
how sad she how insecure she was about
being in there most inspiring person is
one overcoming the fear of doing
something not the person who's excellent
when you're in a lab going and crapped
in a music is this somebody that you
think about from your past that you like
you know what therapy sounds such a
sense gave me a wedgie
whoa forever the sound that girl in
fronted on me I do this for that you
know I do this for that no it's more
it's more the influential people that I
know I don't really think about me but I
did negative thanks to me I think about
the individuals like like Wayne like
Ross like yeh like the guys that I know
you know if I take tonight off I know
that one of them is probably in the
studio practice something magical you
know so I should probably stay a little
longer I should probably not go to the
club I should just you know work because
I know that there's somebody else
working if I decide to go play you know
I'm saying so I just use like
individuals you know and especially like
probably one of the most influential
people like in that regard
obviously it's Wayne but you know as
well Jay is one of those guys so that's
one that like you can guarantee if he's
going in there rapping it's gonna be
something something great so I just use
people you know I use positive
inspiration as opposed to like actually
a bit like oh man Agosto that's all good
I'm in a great positive headspace right
now I don't
like to appreciate this music and I know
you've heard this but my question is how
much do you do it and that is visually
visualization and we call it highly
engaged visualization visualization
where you're seeing yourself doing
something and your emotive Li there
you're literally closing your eyes and
meditating on the experience you're
seeing and feeling it sensing it and
it's not the kind of visualization
you've probably been taught to do which
is just all the buoyant victory
everything's great victory hey
everything's awesome perfect it's the
visualization where you also imagine see
and feel the struggle on purpose let me
give an example lots of people when
they're new to you know performance
training and have had a lot of
experience they would say oh wait you
know if you're gonna run a marathon
imagine yourself crossing that vision
and finish line you know your arms up
and victory everything is great you
cross that finish line there's your
family and they give you big hugs and
you feel great still vital energized
ready to kick some butt you know you
could run another 20 miles you're you're
the strongest most powerful you ever
know I'm like oh wow you know that's
just a person who hasn't got a lot of
training or actual high performance
coaching in their life because the
better thing to imagine is what happens
at mile 13 to imagine yourself running
to starting running running strong but
also seeing and sensing and feeling
yourself at mile 13 when that decision
point comes to want to quit that's where
I want you to also enter the scene and
visualize seeing yourself struggle like
seeing the perspiration seeing the
heartache seeing the hurt the pain that
like I can't run anymore dude seeing
yourself make a decision at that point
to be resilient to keep at it to see the
charge come back on your face to see
yourself working through the struggle is
the most important visualization you can
do what would you say to yourself when
it sucks not just see yourself validated
it's about look the real truth of
achieving any dream is that struggle
that effort that
and I know you know this so my question
is when is the last time you just gave
yourself a few moments free away from
you know playing on the phone free away
from the internet just to sit down by
yourself to visualize and daydream about
your dreams about the activities
involved in that about how you would
struggle through about what it would
feel like to be victorious all of it the
whole thing the messy part the ugly part
what would you say to yourself when it
gets hard that's what you need to do to
truly actualize a dream we got to begin
with seeing it and sensing it the good
the bad the easy the difficult and the
victory shacks future is certain a big
shift in the balance of power in the NBA
as the Leafs most dominant player is
headed back east the newest member of
the Miami Heat remember this I'm gonna
bring a championship to Miami I promise
I thought we split apart were you trying
to give more more championships in me oh
absolutely
you are absolutely and I knew you're
gonna get one I knew you want because of
the energy you're going into Miami and D
Way and everything that was there I knew
you're gonna get that one so I knew I
had to get at least two or three I
wanted you to get that it's I needed
that I wanted that I got wanted people
to say Z see this is what they're
missing here this is what they gave up
for right
Kobe should have been the one to go now
he's in Miami's we´d like I needed that
I wanted that I wanted everybody to hate
me I wanted to fuel off of that and just
come back with so much anger so much
vengeance so I wanted that so when you
won right after you won I went out to
the track and I ran I did my
conditioning I did my drills or one up
the next morning I hit my weights at the
my house and shots I did everything
humanly possible to get myself ready but
I was I needed outside yeah good good I
knew the two
all of the influences come out
everywhere I mean you get influences
from everything you get inspiration from
like I could literally like look at this
bag and be like look at how the zipper
is and look at how like the shapes go
like this and how the colors change and
how the belt buckles like this like you
know the way that the belt buckles are
like the way that it clips or the way
that it tugs and whatever any you can
get any inspiration from anything to
write a song to make a shirt to like
come up with a video you know like it
just comes over comes out of everything
you can look at you know you can get
creative and inspired by anything really
so I think I'm definitely always doing
that I'd say and like letting it out and
in song writing and singing and the way
that I perform and the way that I you
know act and stuff like that inspires me
more and more real life inspires me but
but what inspired me to begin with is
just as so many of you are just a huge
film fan and the films of piracy
primarily release ago you know influence
on me Stanley Kubrick terrence malick
Nicolas Roeg just the extraordinary
world of body and great directors I
think primarily and I know that almost
anybody who's here today we talked about
seeing Star Wars for the first time
because from my generation that truly
was a watershed moment and something
that fed my enthusiasm from ancient Rome
Genesis stuck with me but I think the
last thing could go one way or another
have the opportunity to make new films
which I feel very brave inspires we want
to try and work that warranted I could
find the inspiration from like if I hear
if I ever really go out for instance I
can be like on this would be cool but
you could do it like this and say you
know what I mean so you get like
inspiration but then again you get
inspiration from all types of musics
really I mean you can go listen to no
great range all track and get really
inspired by by like just a certain
rhythm or whatever you know and then try
to make something out of that and try to
make it into your own thing inside most
of my rhythmic growth is evolutionary so
that what I've worked on grows into
something else grows into something else
but there have been the odd time that I
would call epiphanies like that and
there's a rhythm that I used a lot in
the late 80s or so Nigerian music West
African music with a slightly displaced
accents in it and I heard that I was in
a village in Togo in West Africa on your
ten-speed on after having my bicycle
that time and just I heard this rhythm
echoing across the valley and it was
just two drummers with hand drums
playing it and it engraved itself on my
mind and became a huge influence on me
rhythmically after that because I had
been listening to King Sonny a day was a
pioneer for Nigerian pop music and a
certain certain real mix rhythmic accent
syncopations that was based on that I
was very influenced by at the time and
then this other rhythm
that I I heard that time in Togo was
from that same heart and the music that
I heard no it lodges itself am i
bringing it it in grief itself in there
and and then that becomes something
special and those are rare I think when
you're suddenly a hit by something
that's that strong reggae the first time
reggae music really got into my soul and
I felt that upbeat downbeat mention IRA
God again I'll never forget it was a Bob
Marley song natural mystic yeah just
sitting in a car and hearing that song
and I suddenly I got it you know I got
what reggae was all about where I'd
heard it before but hadn't got it I'm
inspired about you know life and all
sorts of things you can say something
right now and wouldn't inspired me to
write a song or something that happen
you know most Kings just happen to be
inspired by Basquiat drawing you know
they drawn and yet most young kings get
their head cut off on the bottom and I
looked at that and I was like it's
powerful you know this is the statement
in itself you know lends itself for a
song song starts inspired by Basquiat my
chariots on fire everybody took shots
hit my body up I'm tired internist is a
build me up to break me down to build me
up again they like hope we need you back
so we could kill yes again you know it's
like this thing that's love/hate thing
that the world has with success period
and my own artists have my own vision
I suppose that there's one
interpretation of the female to sing a
love song and look pretty and just you
know I guess do what everyone thinks you
should do but it's just not what
inspires me and I'm inspired not just by
you know what I see
in terms of the future of music or tech
or or fashion I see also my fans and I
think about what they want to experience
and they love to feel out of touch with
reality for a moment so it might feel
shocking maybe but I really think it's
just this sort of surreal fantasy that I
take pleasure in creating for you well
we all know about your love for custom
otto how much of him is in you when
you're doing this I don't know I'm just
not him
maybe I'm if I continue to do this for
another 20 years or so I may I may be
somewhere in there close to his level of
protection of his fighters but as of now
enormous it's not that I miss not as
season experiences as mr. D'Amato was
you speak of him in the present tense
he's very much with you at all times
pretty much yeah very much would you
have him is one of the most special
people in your life absolutely no one
could inspire me as much as he you know
if I was discouraging I think you know
because sometimes I'm sure in your field
he said what really things may got
difficult something may happen in your
life I don't want to do this no more we
all go through that I don't want to do
this no more and he would inspire me to
say hey this is the route to go he would
inspire me to wanna do many times I quit
boxing before I became a professional
boxer advantage I quit I didn't want to
do it and he gave me the desperation or
even but why I should be doing this here
have you seen as an inspirational figure
well I just wrote many people probably
in the early stage when I was growing up
I would say my mother was my inspiration
because she she didn't go to school to
study very much here's a fourth grade
fifth grade probably and that's all
about education yet but very unique
character
the open very helping pay persons as he
always inspired me on that whatever this
she did the other one inspiration I get
from the people that I work with all
these women that work in the village
they how hard their life is and how they
worked so hard to make a little
difference in their life to make sure
their children don't have to go to the
misery that she has gone through that's
the only thing she does and she's so
committed given this tiny money she gets
in her hand she tries to get the best
mileage out of this money when she
received this first money when you give
her loan from Grameen Bank as I said the
initial loan will be about $30 or $35
when she holds this money she literally
shakes she cannot stand still because
she cannot believe anybody could trust
her with such an enormous amount of
money she thinks this is such a huge
money she doesn't know what how to
handle this money so that's what the
shaking part comes and the inside of her
key she keeps promising anybody who has
trusted her all this money didn't ask
for anything just gave her the money on
the basis of the trust she will give her
life to make sure that Trust is kept and
her I shall be tears will be running
down from her eyes not believing that
this real is it's not a dream as a real
thing and the rest of her life she
struggles to make sure she makes that
thing true that yes she her trust will
never be broken and that's what keeps
the whole Grameen Bank microcredit
together the relationship of trust
between the two now I've got a special
bonus clip that I think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
best live 30 questions of the day it's
not enough to just watch a video if you
want to change your life you have to do
something and take action so pull out
your worksheets and answer these three
questions and if you don't have the
worksheets check the link in the
description below to get them for free
question number one what inspired you to
join best live 30 question number two
what
an inspired life look like for you and
question number three if you wake up
tomorrow uninspired how will you find
your inspiration and if you're doing the
best life 30 challenge with me put a
hashtag best life 30 down the comments
below so we can celebrate with you the
difference between outstanding and
average is what you do when it gets hard
people with an average mindset only do
things when it's easy because it's easy
anyone can do it but life is coming for
you
setbacks they're coming for you and
that's what separates the average from
the outstanding your goals they don't
count until it's hard so I had a new guy
on my team who's writing to me to say
Evan super important this is urgent I
need help with my schedule I'm just not
seeing consistent I'm not staying on my
goals I know what I want to get done for
you but also for my life and and it's
not unless it's some deadline or you're
on me it's not happening I'm not
consistent on it how do how do I get
going how do I stay consistent and said
we work together through the schedule
and we created his calendar and say what
are your goals and put it in your
calendar and how do you want each day to
go I mean he plotted out his Saturday to
Sunday you know the whole week and then
I asked him okay now put in your morning
routine what do you want to do every day
right so you plotted that into his
calendar and now he's got this weekly
schedule of what he's gonna do every
morning and then every day doing
different things and how he wants his
ideal life to go awesome and then I told
them what really mattered like this is
great your actions now to your missions
is really important but following
through on your calendar doesn't count
until it's hard
maybe maybe today is gonna be easy for
you maybe tomorrow is easy for you
because we talked because you're
motivated cuz you're inspired like yeah
yeah yeah I'm gonna do it awesome what
happens when you don't sleep well what
happens when something happens in your
family what happens when the website
crashes what happens when cell that
happens what happens when you've lost
some motivation energy what happened to
get some bad news
what happens what do you do this is
where most people crumble this is where
most people as soon as there's one
little tiny thing that interrupts them
they're gone they fall off their entire
schedule and routine your goals suddenly
don't matter anymore you don't think
they're possible your goals don't count
until they're hard that's what I told
them
- listen listen to me this is a great
plan that light that you wrote that's a
great life what you wrote down on your
calendar that's a great life for you
that's what you want imagine if you did
that every day for the next year how
different would your life look like one
year from today if you were consistent
and seen like oh yeah yeah amazing I
mean great doesn't count until it's hard
none of this matters until it's hard
life is coming for you get ready and
what I want him and I want you to
realize is that you need to expect it
because you're working your calendar and
it's great and here we go we're getting
our getting our objectives and going for
our goals and then when something hits
us in the face you're surprised by it
you're shocked and then you fall off
course don't be surprised expect it
expect the difficulty expect the road
bump expect somebody to punch you in the
face like expected it's coming and this
is your chance to be outstanding because
everybody else is gonna be average if
you want to join the best life 30
challenge with me check out the link
right there below me or if you want more
inspiring videos check the playlists
right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there